free divers it is a very dangerous sport
because for most people when carbon
dioxide levels increase in the
bloodstream and brain triggers this gas
reflux what free divers train is carbon
dioxide tolerance so one way is you can
do what's called cyclic hyperventilation
if you do that 25 times or so and you
think oh you're bringing a lot of oxygen
you are but you're also offloading a lot
of carbon dioxide especially if you use
forceful exhales and then if you were to
hold your breath what you would find is
you could hold your breath for a lot
longer why because your carbon dioxide
levels are reduced so you don't have the
same impulse to breathe if you do that
before going underwater but your carbon
dioxide is then lower you're going to be
able to stay under longer the way they
die is they'll just be swimming feeling
completely calm because they've trained
up the CO2 tolerance and when they die
they don't suddenly feel like oh my
goodness I'm running out of air it's
just lights go black and so they're
alive and then they're gone it's not
because the gas reflex is kicked in it's
because their gas reflexes being so
desensitized that it's after the point
at which they die precisely